puis qu'on m'a présenté il ya quelques
mois déjà son ouïe cause du 3 pro ico
view 3 je vous ai déjà parlé du lui
connu trois fois il ya déjà huit ans et
ils ont annoncé ils ont présenté dans
quelques jours une version spéciale
édition du week of view 3 vous avez la
boîte ici vous avez le smartphone là
alors qu'on travaille très vite et on
s'est dit tiens un nouveau view 3
pourquoi pas intéressant on va
recommencer re design et alors ce qu'on
va faire aujourd'hui c'est que je vais
vous montrer de cette spéciale édition
du week au but 3 vous dire comment il
est comment est ce produit n'est ce
qu'il ya dans la boîte on peut trouver
c'est toutefois il vous intéresse les
promesses qui sont faites avec on va
regarder aussi le week of view 3d c'est
de faire le test de ce smartphone de
pouvoir vous dire ce que j'en pense
comment ils et comment se place oui qu
aujourd'hui par rapport au marché et qui
on donnerait tout ça
[Musique]
vous savez cette année oui qu ont
sélectionné trois créateurs des
créateurs ils font partie de leur équipe
savoir que oui qu à pas mal de monde qui
travaille auprès du graphique d'un point
de vue design au sein de l'équipe est
depuis longtemps un appel à projet en
disant faites nous des propositions que
l'on retient trois et ils les auront
leur modèle spécialisation sur le vieux
3 l'idée est vachement sympa plutôt
original ça motive les études ça fait un
très joli projet et on a donc ses
modèles là pour ce lieu trois là trois
modèles moi ce gic g le nom tant que je
vous le dise je crois vous disent pas
dit il il s'appelle chaussée l'aigreur
cessa explosion floral c'est yael bac et
qu'il l'a créé bravo gaël une édition
spéciale qui est plutôt sympa bien
dessiné des package est jolie petite
boîte c'est bien là qu'est ce que j'aime
bien en plus c'est ça design in france
ils auraient pu nous marquer dessinée en
france aurait été sympa plutôt que de le
mettre en anglais mais bon pas bien
grave à l'intérieur de la boîte dont ce
week-end spécial édition alors là vous
retrouve énormément votre smartphone et
que j'ai déjà enlevé parce que j'ai déjà
testé bien évidemment vous vous en
douterez on ouvre et là on arrive un
truc sympa petit créa qui a été fait
c'est très joli
alors bon ça il faut aimer bien
évidemment le travail qu'a fait madame
kenya dessus et moi j'aime bien tout ça
assez joli c'est bien évidemment floral
on retrouve tout une explication en
anglais et en français en dessous ouvrir
un monde d'opportunités à nos
communautés bon si ça vous intéresse
regardez fait une capture d'écran
attention top voilà ça vous pouvez le
lire sympa on a les petits autocollants
qui ont été faits à partir de de la
création c'est assez original plutôt
plutôt s'attendent à voir là dedans on
retrouve ensuite à l'intérieur de leur
fera pas y arriver
de quoi aurait bien évidemment votre
tiroir de cartes sim à l'intérieur on a
froid à regarder vois ça la petite coque
spéciale édition
enfin quand on nous a annoncé une soirée
pour nous présenter la spéciale les
special edition urico view 3 je suis
plutôt cool où il co art design et sont
venus trois lors penser qu'effectivement
il n'avait pas revu en tout cas les
specs ce normal ces modèles il reste
comme il est je me suis dit tiens ils
vont nous proposer un fonds revu corrigé
refait pour lui 3 et ben non ils nous
ont proposé une coque alors après c'est
une jolie coque c'est design et il ya un
beau travail un travail de création qui
fait qui est très sympa mais néanmoins
ça m'a surpris aussi tiens ils ont
peut-être le faire un truc différent
pour le modèle est en fait non ce
special edition cesser une coque en
plastique transparentes et voilà voilà
alors pourquoi pas c'est sympa mais
qu'en fait ce qu'il ya c'est que oui qu
un blouson site actualitté et a besoin
de présence de couverture média pour
qu'on puisse parler d'eux pour pouvoir
générer des ventes l'année dernière ils
ont effectivement plusieurs lancements
use view de pro en début d'année il est
2 heures claude alors je parviens bêtise
il ya eu le view de plus et j'ai longé
le nom de notre modèle ce qui fait qu'il
a sorti quatre modèles dans la série
view l'année dernière cette année
l'argent sorti savoir effectivement
oublie qu'on rencontre des difficultés
c'est pas hyper hyper évident le marché
est compliqué il était compliqué en des
médias utilisent toujours autant voire
plus
en 2019 avec un peu d'écrémage qui était
attaché au lit collomb je pense que
c'est pour ça que cette année ils n'ont
pas pris les risques au travail je n'ai
pas eu les moyens ou je sais pas
exactement le pourquoi du comment il n'y
a pas eu d'autres produits de sortie
donc l'idée de la marque veut dire il
faut qu'on fasse parler nous il faut
qu'on puisse toujours être présent
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à moindre
coût et devra faire des special edition
alors pourquoi pas ça pourrait faire en
tout cas un effet de pétard mouillé
on vit dans un truc un petit peu spécial
un peu original et au final c'est
exactement le même produit avec juste
une coque transparente bonbons à
l'intérieur de la tombe à retrouver ses
petits écouteurs qui sont de ceux qui
sont obligatoires dans les boîtes
françaises et le projet coutteure vous
avez votre petit bloc de charge qui est
juste là est en dessous si vous regardez
là vous avez up votre câble de recharge
usb micro usb
à côté de ça les actes du smartphone
n'est pas complètement dingue on se
retrouve avec un menton qui assez grand
et sa fin 2019 c'est pas terrible
terrible alors après on est vraiment sûr
de l'entrée de gamme donc c'est pas
demain petit peu de comprendre pourquoi
effectivement le smartphone est comme ça
les bords sur les côtés ne dérange pas
le fédéral à petit en cochant ou
pourquoi pas on est dans ce qui s'est
fait cette année ça marche le petit haut
parleur qui est caché là ça marche
également bouton de volume bouton pour
l'allumer en dessous vous avez un haut
parleur ici mono le micro la connectique
en micro usb ici tiroirs de cartes sim
prise jack qui conservait ça c'est cool
le micro pour la réduction de bruit et à
l'arrière vous avez un triple module
photo qui est là qu'on va détailler dans
quelques instants le capteur d'empreinte
digitale le branding nico la norme ce
bon voilà le smartphone est pas mal la
prise en main est franchement correct on
trouve très facilement la zone pour
placer son doigt pour venir débrouiller
ça c'est un grand standard mais ça
marche il faut de plus parfaitement bien
c'est maîtrisé à savoir calment vous
avez une dalle ips
6,26 pouces de diagonale et on est sur
du hd + 1560 par 720 pixels à 268 pixels
par pouce alors moi comme ça cet écran
il me dérange pas même si on n'est pas
sur du full hd n'aime ce n'est pas sur
un écran dingue je trouve malgré tout
assez intéressant mais sur un smartphone
qui coûte 179 euros et 99 centimes on
n'est pas sur un smartphone haut de
gamme on n'est pas sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme
on est vraiment sur l'entrée de gamme là
dessus pour regarder du contenu
multimédia
ça marche vous connais pas le dessus
parce que j'ai tout de suite fait
ressortir un petit peu pixels c'est pas
officines ça fonctionne il est néanmoins
suffisamment lumineux même en extérieur
ça marche c'est pas là vous allez avoir
le plus de luminosité mais ça fonctionne
donc bon de ce côté là en tout cas ça le
temps est maintenant tout son cachet un
peu plus dubitatif c'est l'audio vous
avez un haut parleur mono situe juste la
tempe alors là ne fonctionne pas on est
sur un smartphone haut de gamme cela ne
paraît pas proscrire des crayons n'est
par contre le son là est vraiment très
très très prudent lorsque vous touchez
le son à fond sur 7 sur tout de suite
parce que vous en rendez compte
les ça ça fait mal ça fait très mal aux
oreilles on a un son pied médium et qui
franchement ça tullow alors là il ya du
méthane autre regard sur moi que ça
c'est sûr mais ça cette sorte comme ça
le son fait mais ce n'est vraiment pas
agréable
si vous voulez en profiter il faut le
bcme tout de suite on n'entend plus rien
et ça c'est quand même un petit peu
dommage
j'attrape un petit peu l'histoire c'est
cette fois branché à une prise jack
c'est vrai que vous avez votre prise
jack 3.5 qui situe juste en haut sur le
smartphone ici et ça soit un petit peu
l'histoire la bande passante est
meilleur on récupère plus de grave
médium grave on est moins serein sont
criants mais par contre vous pousser le
son à fond leur attention portée je vous
les oreilles je vous dis une fois de
plus mais si vous mettez vraiment de son
fort si vous décidez et ben saada saturé
à la qualité pas complètement ouf
néanmoins pour avoir un truc qui est un
peu moins mauvais je dirais il faut
quand même aller sur un casque après il
ya ce qui est pas au fond plus c'est la
performance vous avez derrière un
médiathèque un ailier au p 22
il m'a un petit peu de temps à réagir
lorsque voulait par exemple ouvrir votre
appareil photo vous cliquez il faut
attendre pour que ça s'ouvre les
changements prennent quand même
relativement temps il faut prendre son
mal en patience jusqu'à ce que les
choses deviennent sourds ça c'est un
petit peu le le reproche que je pourrais
faire du smartphone vous avez votre
médiathèque est liée au p 22 vous avez 3
giga de ram vous avez 64 giga du
stockage extensible jusqu'à 250 gigas
grâce à une carte microsd
vous avez quand même une certaine
latence et ça c'est pas terrible
terrible à côté de ça vous pouvez pas
jouer à des jeux trop gourmand pour les
jouer à des jeux qui sont pas trop trop
gourmand ici par exemple un asphalte
mais une fois de plus il faut s'armer de
patience il faut attendre attendre
attendre et attendre encore lorsque vous
jouez le jeu le duo fait très très très
mal de son trait médium c'est pas hyper
hyper vérité après en terme de
performance et pas ou feint vous avez un
score surtout de 80 4508 vous vous
classez nous marque 3 1 % des
utilisateurs dépasser c'est à dire qu'on
est vraiment en bas du classement en
tout ou alors vous me direz un chiffre
ça fait pas tout mais si on compare par
rapport à ce qui se fait par rapport à
la concurrence aujourd'hui le vrai
problème du bruit causé la concurrence
ce qui en face aux mêmes tarifs
eh bien on se rend compte que ce
smartphone iv ou chou à rennes nice elle
faisait un score de plus de 103 mille
ayant réduit note 7 143 milles par
contre un point sur lequel se view 3
special edition est drôlement bien c'est
l'autonomie vous avez une très grosse
batterie de 4000 mais lyon perd alors ça
c'est cool
par contre on aide la recharge qui est
assez lente il nous faut plus de 2h 2h
2h30 pour recharger votre smartphone de
0 à 100% s'est récemment il faut pas
être pressé
pensez bien à le recharger tous les deux
jours normalement tu vas être tranquille
quand même sur deux jours cette année où
il compte arriver avec un triple module
photo à l'arrière de ses smartphones
plutôt intéressant plutôt bien belles
promesses qui sont face aux cas sur le
view 3 points sur le vieux troyes alors
sur ce vieux troyes on a un capteur
principal de 12 mégapixels
on a un capteur très grand-angle 120° de
13 mégapixels et puis un capteur de 2
mégapixels qui cache est juste là c'est
pour le mode portrait pour les faits
évoqués ou avoir un zoom numérique
jusqu'à foix iv vous pouvez filmer en
vidéo jusqu'en 1080p et à la banque vous
avez votre petite caméra qui planque et
là c'est une 8 mégapixels alors moi je
me serais dit tiens on nous propose des
choses intéressantes on peut faire
différents types de photos wiko céline
par rapport à ce que fait la concurrence
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant ça
c'est sans papiers dans les faits le
résultat est nettement moins bien
intéressant qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
croire je vous demandais photo je
voulais donc directement ici sur mon
macbook pro pour pas se laisser
influencer par rapport à la colorimétrie
de l'écran luminosité ou c'est à fond là
on est sans capteur principal alors son
capteur principal qu'est ce qu'on voit
on voit que l'arrière ici est nette mais
par contre l'avant est floue et ça ça ne
pose problème on arrive sur la deuxième
photo qui est le capteur ultra grand
angle on a une grosse différence de
colorimétrie on est une des formations
déjà au niveau de l'image en ici vous le
voyez on a une belle des formations au
niveau de l'image au niveau des arrondis
sur le côté mais bon ça sera du très
grand angle c'est pas extrêmement
surprenant que les sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme donc ça va pas trop
trop lui en vouloir
un autre point sur lequel va pas trop en
vouloir mais qui pourtant est vraiment
là c'est la différence du colorimétrie
garder la couleur des arbres on est sur
l'espèce de verre très saturées qui tire
à peu sur le jaune qui pas très très
joli et là on arrive sur un autre verre
pareil ici on tient vraiment sur le
jaune sur ses feuilles la chasse aux
petits jeunes a disparu la gemmi au
format paysage
et là pour le coup tout de suite il n'y
a absolument aucune stabilisation une
fois de plus on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme ça j'ai pas trop lui
en vouloir mais avec moi sa part de ne
pas du tout sur l'ultra grand-angle tout
de suite voyez on est une différence au
niveau de l'exposition d'un bout de
soleil karibe là ça nous flingue tout
c'est pas très très beau c'est très
déformée ça c'est pas exploitable
jeunesse et à lui faire un zoom jusqu'à
foix iv
c'est vraiment pas beau ça lis
énormément après on n'est pas serein
smartphones qui est fait pour faire du
jour nous ont mis un zoom x 4 et pour
pallier aux défauts du smartphone est
bien là ce traitement derrière d'image
qui va lisser énormément et qui est
vraiment pas beau du tout on continue à
piller photos plus sur le capteur
principal objectif principal toujours le
fameux problème d'exposition l'un avait
du soleil n'en avait pas du coup ça m'a
complètement cramé cette partie là ici
ça ne crame également sur la feuille
le reste est malgré tout assez juste
sursaturé quand même mais bon ça
fonctionne et qu'on passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle on est un peu manquera mais
par contre c'est les formant ses moins
bons c'est beaucoup moins précis moins
sûr c'est pas terrible
tout se soit capteur principal alors là
le point je sais pas où ils essaient
flûte partout s'illustra grand-angle bon
toujours différence de colorimétrie
toujours du fou c'est pas terrible
là je me suis un peu rapproché c'est
toujours flou je sais pas s'il ya un
point qui était quelque part c'est pas
terrible en live sur l'ultra grand saut
et l'aca flagrant les couleurs sont pas
du tout les mêmes
regardez là on est plus sur du verre sur
la partie claire tandis que là on est
sur l'espèce de verre un peu jaune
sursaturé c'est vraiment pas très beau
la caméra de celle ci par contre fait le
job elle lis pas trop c'est assez
naturel ça ça me va parce que dès qu'on
arrive sur le mode nuit mais ça s'est
relativement normal nous ont bien menu
parce qu'il faut amener parce que tout
le monde fait du mode nuit
par contre il faut nourrir et de la
lumière on y voit absolument rien même
avec le grand temps que ça ne marche
absolument pas d'ailleurs là le mode
portrait que dire là je suis un peu sur
une belle déconvenue sur le mode
portrait parce que je suis bon track
aime bien le détour un petit peu
regardée alors le visage ça semble aller
à peu près ça me faire un peu les petits
cheveux ça c'est bon c'est pas
complètement anormal par contre au
niveau des doigts c'est vraiment pas
très très beau jeu pas sur une autre
photo j'ai eu du mal en fait
même avec un décompte de 5 secondes pour
pouvoir poser à garder les yeux ouverts
j'ai eu un peu de mal ça bouge tout le
temps bon voilà en fait up pleine galère
je finis par y arriver là je dis ah ok
du mode portrait alors là j'ai vraiment
fermé hier j'ai fait exprès souhaitera f
2.0 voir un petit
en dessous et qu'est-ce qui se passe il
ya si vous regardez bien j'ai mon oeil
ici c'est parti là kenneth là je suis
complètement dans le flou est alors ne
parlons pas des doigts les doigts sont
floues y absolument aucun détour âgées
des semblants de trucs là mais c'est
franchement dégoûtant et là c'est pareil
tout est flou tous les côtés bon voilà
pour moi il ya le boulot l'être au
niveau du mode portrait c'est vraiment à
revoir
bon alors moi une question que je me
pose c'est un smartphone qui coûte quand
même je vous le dis cette année 110 pack
des petits 179 euros 99 se trouve à la
capitale est très très rapidement une
jolie petite coque mais on lui-même dans
le design
bon c'est très standard aujourd'hui très
très très classique il a une excellente
autonomie
l'écran est convenable l'audio n'est pas
bon les photos ne sont pas bonnes non
plus lisez wehrung rapidement ça c'est
plutôt bien en termes de performance
s'est pas complètement ouf ça va patrick
ya beaucoup de latence aurait donc sur
une expérience globale que je trouve
assez mauvaise
en tout quatre moyennes basses est assez
mauvaise alors on va re situer on est
sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
on va se dire c'est normal que sur un
smartphone entrée de gamme on en ait
pour son argent
vous mettez 180 euros sera demandée bien
vous allez pour 180 euros vous n'allez
pas dans un truc hyper performant vous
n'êtes pas voir des grandes halles de
dubaï terrible c'est assez normal c'est
ce que j'aurais tendance à penser
sauf que et je suis pas le seul et c'est
ce que font les consommateurs vous
regardez la concurrence vous regardez ce
qu'il y a ils vont regarder les
propositions de valeur et d'avoir pour
un tarif sensiblement équivalent à 20 30
euros prix en dessous mais surtout au
dessus et c'est là où on se rend compte
qu'il ya un problème avec nico
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que vous allez
regarder du côté de chez les
constructeurs chinois xiaomi huawei je
pense notamment aux ennemis 7 mai 2009
vous pouvez même trouver mais je l'avais
noté ça vous pouvez trouver aujourd'hui
un rémy notre set aux alentours de 165
euros sur des marketplace chez darty ou
fnac et un score en tout cas 243 me
contre 86 mille ici pareil vont garder
un ps marc 2019 de huawei en termes de
performance vous êtes au dessus en terme
de qualité vous êtes au dessus alors
vous n'allez pas trop tôt complètement
ouf on reste sur notre égard mais par
contre on est dans la même gamme de prix
est la proposition de valeur est
beaucoup plus intéressant que ce soit
pour trouver ici
j'suis con donc la question qu'on peut
se poser c'est est-ce que c'est oui koki
aux fraises et qui arrive pas à se
positionner par rapport à la concurrence
qui arrivé l'année dernière en 2018
c'est un petit peu dur alors il faut
savoir que ce modèle là a été présenté à
barcelone en février 2010 9 ans c'est à
dire que c'est un modèle qui a été conçu
en 2018 je pense que dans quick au
travail déjà depuis quelques mois et va
nous présenter en 2020 des smartphones
sur lesquels ils bossent depuis 2019
maintenant il ya tout qui est très
important pour moi c'est que ce
smartphone là je pense pas qu'il puisse
marcher je pense pas qu'on puisse
convaincre beaucoup de monde je me suis
trop sa tête je suis dit quelle est la
cible de ce smartphone qui sont les
clients potentiels qui vont l'acheter ça
des gens qui cherchent une bonne
autonomie des smartphones dans ses
tarifs la bonne autonomie
vous retrouverez une question le
meilleur sur plein d'autres points que
n'est pas aujourd'hui ce vieux troll ça
veut donc dire que ce smartphone n'a pas
proposition de valeur qui est
suffisamment intéressante par rapport à
ce qu'est la concurrence ça veut donc
dire que si louis cau continue comme ça
nous proposer des smartphones qui sont
au final mi figue mi raisin bien il
risque un moment ou à un autre d'aller
franchement dans le mur alors après il
faut aussi repositionné les choses week
aujourd'hui passé sous capital chinois
avec tin oo ils ont des problèmes ils
ont aujourd'hui des soucis pour être
concurrentiels et sans le bonus avec ce
vieux troyes clairement que pas comment
on pourrait décrire ce smartphone et
coûterait je vais dur mais coûte
récemment héros je dirais allez c'est
pas mal mais à 180 euros c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible c'est ce qui
fait que wilko a deux solutions la
première c'est soisy reconnue sur ce
genre de smartphones avec des
propositions de valeur qui sont assez
basses par rapport à la concurrence
auquel cas j'arrive à de réduire mes
coûts d'achat ou alors à réduire la
marge et à ce moment là je les vends
beaucoup moins cher je suis pas sûr que
ce soit viable à long terme
ou alors ils se disent il faut réussir à
être concurrentiel par rapport aux
acteurs chinois mais ça me semble aussi
difficile vu le nombre d'unités vendues
et vu leur positionnement dans le monde
dont 5 semble relativement dur alors
appris qu on s'est positionné sur le
marché américain
en début d'année je sais absolument pas
s'ils sont bons aujourd'hui là dessus
oui ou non en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que 2018 est une année difficile
pour ico 2019 je pense une année tout
aussi difficile voire même plus dur et
je pense qu'en 2020 ça va être l'année
de tous les challenge allaient tous les
risques soient amicaux avec une nouvelle
proposition de valeur ou un autre
positionnement tarifaire ou alors les
arrive vraiment se réinventer sans quoi
je pense que 2020 cette année un petit
peu charnière on y voit là je suis très
embêté parce que la manne qu'ils
l'aiment bien c'est une marque française
même si aujourd'hui est capital chinois
il ya de super équipe chez ricoh qui
travaillent dur sur leurs produits mais
voilà voilà
je suis relativement dès que dire plus
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire et on se retrouve demain
dans la salle